israeli people who don't have uh an
immediate connection two jews in the
diaspora
do not understand the meaning of this
connection
[Music]
how are you good how are you fantastic
fantastic
you know this next 20 minutes there's a
lot of topics to cover the primary one
in the center of them is the jewish
diaspora and israeli nature
but your work spans across non-profit
organizations beyond that and i would
love to start with your journey
and and where you come from and how you
end up being such an advocate
and a proactive member of the group
that's
that's trying to work through the
complicated nature
of the jewish people so sharon before we
get
to that complicated topic i'd love to
start off with with who you are
and going back all the way to when
you're getting your bachelor's and your
masters
okay so i think that the turning point
for me
was after a few years that i worked in
the israel film fund and i worked in the
national theater habima
and i had like this glamorous uh
positions in very cool places and
it was fun but it wasn't my place
it didn't feel like the right match
so i thought to myself after graduation
okay so i studied this public policy
ema it was very inspiring
but i said to myself something
has to change like my track
wasn't the track so
i just decided okay now i'm going to
act differently i didn't know what i'm
going to do i didn't know what
i'm going to to learn but
i understood that i have to go
and just jump in the water and see how
it goes
so uh one morning
in the summer i sat here in tel aviv in
the center of tel aviv
and drank coffee near my house and i saw
an article
about the education system in israel
and i said to myself okay i want to work
in something
with impact i want to just do something
meaningful
i'm very connected to values in the
nonprofit world
let's see what can i do so one article
talked about the education and it was
like a
table of all the organizations
that work in field uh in-source and
outsourcing
for children of all ages and i saw
that there is a lot of funding for this
uh for this field and it's very
impactful
right and i said to myself okay
if there is so many resources i can find
work right because i wanted to
to step and progress in in my experience
and work in the workspace and i said
okay
let's call all these organizations and i
will find work i was very naive it was
very cute by the way
but things turned differently so i
started calling all these places and
started checking
and trying to find work and
i didn't find work and one place by the
way
got back to me i went to an interview
and
they offered me a very low salary
and i said okay this is not the place
for me
i will not take the first option that i
have
so time goes by i understood that
i think my passion is more of a
unformal education and
[Music]
so i started checking by the way what
was it about education
that that that you were so infatuated
with at that moment
so were you thinking about it for a
while were you just all of a sudden you
were reading the article and you were
like oh okay wow there's this whole
world here that i that i've yet to
explore that makes a lot of sense to me
what was it that really attracted you
to that field i i think
mostly i understood that there are two
million kids
in israel that goes
to learn in the educational system
and it's when you want to affect
society and how it will build and the
future
of israel i think that it's the the most
powerful tool you know because
everybody has to go to school everybody
it doesn't matter which sector you are
so
if you want to impact two million kids i
think it's
it's very impressive right so i think
that you know what apparel that i that i
like to make here
and i i get to talk to quite a few
entrepreneurs that are also that they're
describing the way that they reach their
idea and their their
eventual company is that this is a very
bottoms-up approach right you're looking
at
what's happening okay so we have two
million kids what's common for these two
million kids they're all going to school
on the other hand i'm trying to figure
out how i can make a positive
impact on the state of israel as a whole
and
given that there's two million kids
going to school this is a very direct
way
of pretty much impacting every single
person that's going to grow into this
greater generation that's going to be in
the workforce right if you
impact the education sphere today you're
actually impacting the workforce
in five to ten years and and and it has
it has a big you know butterfly effect
moving forward
and you know for me that makes me
curious about you know how do people
identify key areas that they can have a
positive impact and
i'm thinking about that for myself as
i'm going to go into my own ventures one
day
but i just wanted to set that aside
because that's one of the things that
i'm truly passionate about in uncovering
through this show
yeah so i think that uh when i realized
the capacity
that is impacted and as you mentioned
it's the future of israel at the end of
the day like each country
so what i found out during
seeking for for work not for
anything i didn't even know about
the the existence of the
entrepreneurship world
i wasn't aware of that at all because i
i had this dna
of non-profit i thought okay life
i had like the set of beliefs
that life is a b c and that how it goes
but when i decided to
act differently i had like
different opportunities so i started to
seek for each place meetups
uh places lectures everything
that is beside or
in this content so i started going and i
started asking
people and i met people and i i just
wanted to work by the way i didn't
had any atten intention to
to do anything that is like building or
having
good creation none of that but the thing
is that
the more people that i came across
the more i understood that the
content is getting out of the education
ministry
and that means that kids are learning
different values in different areas in
israel
which means if kids are brought up
in a more developed more uh
wealthy surrounding they will have more
opportunities
and when i was growing up it wasn't like
that it was public school everybody went
to the same school same values same
you know opportunities so you had the
same
cards um yeah
so in a 9 million population it's
we're not a big country but still it's a
game changer when you have more
opportunity opportunities as a child
so how does that then translate to your
passion of
of the jewish diaspora and the israeli
people because until now we're talking
about
you know internally within the state of
israel how education is impacting the
kids growing up
in israel how how do you then you know
become involved with this whole other
you know industry or or ecosystem that
that is not necessarily directly
correlated with the education within
israel
yeah well by chance i got into the
to the discourse of israel diaspora
relationship
i got into this amazing opportunity
through ajc and i'm very grateful
for that i went on a delegation
in to dc at 2016.
and i always was fascinating
but this relationship and personally i
have a family in the u.s
but i never it was by the way the first
time that i was in the us
and until i wasn't there
i didn't understood how
meaningful it was even though i have
family
there so i think that the
the connection between education and
the jewish diaspora israel diaspora
relationship combines that
for me now as reflecting back
uh i think that what we need in society
in israel
is to learn about our history and the
history of
by the way all diaspora not only
american
jews okay because there was a turning
point
israel was established uh it was a
you know race to build a new country
which is a wonder itself right that's
another topic and we we
went to different routes and different
like
challenges in life because where
majority jewish diaspora is minority
so we have a lot a lot of things
that are very different but
the same because we have same history
same values
we share a lot of things together so i
think that
now looking back i think
if local leadership
would embrace the studies
of the holistic
situation and also learning about the
streams
in judaism it will make
us stronger as an as a global nation
and i think it will be very beneficial
for israelis
in general because i think that
personally people who don't
israeli people who don't have uh an
immediate connection
to jews in the diaspora do not
understand the meaning of this
connection
right so i i'd love to provide a little
bit more context
to both you know my israeli friends who
don't necessarily have that direct
connection or to my
american jewish friends who don't
necessarily have that connection or to
anybody in the world that's listening
that doesn't necessarily know
about this this interesting situation
that we're that we're caught up in
so can you give me a little bit of
context how many israelis are there in
israel
how many jews are there outside of
israel where are they located around the
world and
and why aren't everybody just coming
into israel
or or what why is there even an issue
why is it a problem that
they're there and we're here okay
so in israel we're about
seven million give or take something
like that
in the u.s it's somewhere
around as far as i know today five
million maybe five and a half
it's like where it's very similar
capacity
like israel and the north american
uh community in general
there is a small community in russia
there are in
latin america communities so
it's more of the same total i think jews
around the world total minority of like
14 million or something like that it's
like
very very small nation
um i think
that the the situation
now and i'm very passionate as you
mentioned
about it i think that local
leadership is not dealing with the
situation of course we have the covet
now the coronavirus
is like questioning everything
it's like a game changer and we have to
adapt to and solve the problems
regarding health issues regarding the
economics regarding
everything but there's a turning point
that
if the policy making
let's say leaders will not
uh take the situation to their own hands
here i think that it will be very
very the circumstances could be
very very bad so i mean i'm still trying
to understand why what what is the issue
so you know on one level so so on love
one level you know yes i i think that
you know obviously
jews around the world they are support
most of them are are big supporters of
israel they are part of the
the miracle of the nation of israel but
but why
why is there a problem today that there
are
five and a half million jews in the u.s
some in latin america some in russia
some in israel i mean
israel is put is pretty dense right i
mean we there's a lot of people here
uh crowded in the streets and so we
don't necessarily have
room to have you know 17 million people
in israel right now what what is what is
the you know
both what is the issue right now and
what is the
absolute best vision or the ideal
situation that you think
we should strive for if what we have now
is not ideal
okay i think first of all i don't think
that everybody should do alia i
don't hold this like way of thinking i
think that you can be zionist and
live abroad wherever you like because
eventually
israel is the home spiritually
and physically for the jewish nation
so it doesn't matter where you live you
know it's the home
that the jewish people yearn for
like 2 000 years so i think that
everybody
can leverage from the fact that we have
this uh this big present
uh the main gap is because of the
streams
in the last century give or so
there they became a few streams in
judaism
which has different aspects to them
and i think that's the main problem
because the different streams
want to go their way like in israel
most most of israel is belonging to the
orthodoxy
and judaism in the diaspora is
conservative
is reformed and also orthodoxy so there
are
the streams there are different and we
are majority
jews diaspora are minority they have
different
challenges in life sure so we as usually
don't know that
because we're used to hey it's mine
it's a different it's a different game
of course um
so i think that mainly and there was
there is a legislation now
in the knesset of the ministry of
diaspora and
another mk that is dealing with opening
uh a setting of direct consulting
between the knesset
and and the jews and the diaspora
leaders so and it it happened
it doesn't exist and i have to say i'm
very surprised that it didn't exist
today because we belong to the same
nation
of course that this legislation
is not aimed to interfere in sovereignty
because people who are not citizens in
israel cannot
vote therefore cannot decide
about security issues but on matters and
i think it's
very very important and by the way i
have to say and emphasize this is my own
personal opinion that
it's very important to have a discourse
even though you might not the streams
i refer even if the streams will not
agree they have to talk
they have to talk so because there is a
lack of your communication and lack of
knowledge by the way
here and in the diaspora
i think that there is like a
misunderstanding because how we can get
along like this gap
is based on that and if we open a
channel
and accept one another the the streams
it will be
easier to to provide
everybody a future because we have still
the same goals we still
belong to the same nation even though it
expresses different
otherwise like the streams have
different
like day-to-day
they see things differently
but we have seen unfortunately the price
that
the price is heavy prices that the
jewish people
in the last century paid and we don't
want to go back there so sure i have to
say
i think that what you're saying is
absolutely right i think that you know
the miscommunication
the lack of communication or the lack of
effort to really understand and step
into the shoes of the other and
obviously we know that you know
israeli jews they act a little
differently than perhaps american jews
or latin american jews
cultural reasons just like i as in
israeli act differently from a lot of my
friends at stanford they're american and
we accept that
and the difference is that that perhaps
there
i i since i'm situated there i get to
explain myself a lot
and you know my directness and my
husband sometimes may come across
a you know insulting and then i have a
chance to explain
the misunderstanding and i i'm
personally very involved with the fund
called the j
ventures uh with the red cross which i'm
sure that you know because
one of the goals of this fund is to
connect the israeli jews and the
diaspora jews and i believe that he also
took part in one of the programs that
you did
and and and it's been a very rewarding
experience working with
investors and entrepreneurs and
executives both from israel
and from a latin america and russia and
the us and
and all around the world so so i'm
definitely i i understand
the the urgency of what you're saying
and the importance of it
and and i think that and i i get to
enjoy
you know bridging that gap on a daily
basis but toronto before before we have
to end i want to thank you for
for being generous with your time and
for joining me here
and i have to ask for three words that
you would use to describe yourself
i think that the three words that will
describe me is perseverance
uh optimism and uh learning
i think it's very important for evolving
and
i love it shawana thank you very much
this is great
thanks for coming thank you stay safe
and stay healthy
thank you you too bye
you